[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans auditions
publiques au lendemain du premier tour
de la présidentielle premier tour assez
surprenant quels sont les enseignements
et quels sont les stratégies des deux
candidats qualifiés manuel Macron et
Marine Le Pen une heure ce soir deux
invités dans quelques instants
puis Yves réhar pour des questions plus
politiques et c'est avec Julien demande
de Normandie que l'on commence bonjour à
vous merci beaucoup d'être là vous êtes
ministre de l'Agriculture on vous dit
proche du chef de l'État on vous a dit à
un moment d'ailleurs directeur de la
campagne mais la campagne finalement
était bousculée vous ne l'avez pas
dirigé et cette campagne de deuxième
tour après la qualification à un score
de plus de 27% d'Emmanuel Macron et bien
elle semble démarrer de façon différente
c'est une autre campagne aujourd'hui il
était à Denain dans le Nord demain il
sera à Mulhouse et à Strasbourg donc
comment on dit familièrement ça commence
sur les chapeaux de roue peut-être aussi
pour ne pas refaire 2017 bref mais déjà
venin dans les hauts de France ce matin
Sébastien Chenu qui avait tenté la
municipale dans cette localité disait
c'est une provocation il vient dans une
ville qui la contribué à abîmer tout au
long de son quinquennat c'est une
provocation d'aller à Denain là où
Marine Le Pen est arrivé en tête hier je
crois absolument pas bien au contraire
mais vous savez
ayez des discussions avec les habitants
de Denain regardez quand vous prenez
l'histoire de cette ville c'est une
ville qui a profondément subi la
désindustrielle des industrialisations
une ville qui a profondément patie du
chômage une ville où ces dernières
années le gouvernement en lien avec la
collectivité locale et notamment je
salue la mère de Denain qui fait un
travail extraordinaire à massivement
investi pour regagner notamment des
emplois notamment des industries qui
viennent se repositionner dans cette
ville et le président candidat était cet
après-midi non seulement à la rencontre
des habit de Donna mais également à la
rencontre de personnes travaillant sur
les chantiers les chantiers liés aux
investissements que nous avons porté et
donc ce qui est très important dans ce
déplacement vous l'avez dit c'est que
c'est d'abord une nouvelle campagne une
campagne qui s'ouvre cette campagne du
deuxième tour le deuxième élément c'est
que vous avez un candidat qui est au
contact avec les Français qui a passé
qui a passé vous savez moi qui le
connaît depuis longtemps et qui a eu
l'occasion de de d'être à ses côtés dans
bon nombre de déplacements je pense que
nous avons un candidat ou président qui
a toujours été à la rencontre des
Français toutes celles et ceux qui le
suivent dans un déplacement voit à quel
point il va à la rencontre des Français
je pense qu'on ne peut pas lui faire ce
reproche puis le troisième élément qui
est très important c'est que cette
politique en faveur de la création de
l'emploi en faveur de du retour
d'investissement y compris dans des
villes qui ont connu de graves
difficultés du fait de cette des
industrialisation
bien c'est un élément du bilan de notre
quinquennat songer madame Martichoux que
depuis 15 ans dans notre pays nous
n'avions jamais réouvert des industries
pour la première fois nous avons réussi
à ouvrir plus d'industries que nous
n'enfermions
de ce qu'un justement il s'est mis comme
on dit maintenant à porter d'engueulade
il a croisé des habitants de Denain on a
senti leurs colères il a un bilan ce
bilan pour ses habitants il est négatif
parce qu'ils ont comme ressenti de ne
pas avoir vu leur quotidien améliorer
donc certes manuel Macron n'est pas
comptable de la désindustrialisation qui
a été entamée il y a des décennies il
doit maintenant apporter le poids comme
d'autres mais ces habitants là vous
n'allez pas leur expliquer que le bilan
est bon vous allez avoir du mal à les
convaincre ne faites donc comment les ne
faut jamais faire de généralités je peux
vous dire que les ouvriers qui la
rencontrer ensuite cet après-midi eux
pouvaient attester du fait que grâce à
ces politiques menées par la mairie de
Denain menée par le gouv mener en appui
avec les collectivités locales et bien
enfin on retrouvait qui
d'infrastructures qui d'entreprises qui
venait
moi j'ai été c'est pour ça que c'est
pour ça que je vous dis il ne faut pas
faire une généralité deuxièmement vous
avez
eu le bon nombre de rencontres bon
nombre d'échanges ou de manière évidente
et c'est d'ailleurs très intéressant
vous savez en 2017 il y avait un sujet
principal qui était le sujet de l'emploi
on parlait comment pouvons-nous faire
pour réduire pour réduire le chômage ça
n'est plus la priorité pourquoi ça n'est
plus la priorité parce que tout
simplement nous n'avons jamais eu un
taux de chômage aussi bas dans notre
pays pourquoi nous avons cette situation
parce que nous avons fait les réformes
nécessaires en revanche aujourd'hui il y
a un deuxième sujet de préoccupation
absolue qui est celui du pouvoir
d'achats de cet après-midi ont porté
là-dessus qu'elle est aujourd'hui dans
le choix les projets qui sont face à
face celui du candidat Emmanuel Macron
ou la candidate Marine Le Pen quel est
le projet du pouvoir d'achat et après
c'est clairement celui d'Emmanuel Macron
on verra ça avec Tom et Brigitte dans un
instant Marine Le Pen est là l'intention
et peut-être l'intérêt aussi de faire de
ce second tour un référendum anti Macron
comment répondre je crois que les
Français
ont besoin d'avoir un débat qui soit le
débat de la clarté il faut arrêter avec
le anti il faut un débat de la clarté et
moi j'insiste dessus parce que ces deux
semaines doivent permettre cette clarté
et la clarté sur des sujets absolument
importants on vient de parler de celui
du pouvoir d'achat quand vous prenez des
propositions de pouvoir d'achat de
Marine Le Pen elles sont bien moins
dixentes que celles que nous avons déjà
mis en oeuvre notamment sur le bouclier
tarifaire électricité gaz quand vous
prenez la clarté sur un débat aussi
important que l'Europe il faut que cette
clarté soit sur la table parce que vous
avez une Marine Le Pen qui est encore
cet après-midi a dit ah mais moi je vous
assure je ne veux pas sortir de l'Europe
Marine Le Pen et j'ai fait l'exercice
avant-hier j'ai regardé avec précision
la façon qu'elle a de budgéter son
programme songer que dans son dans son
document qui est en ligne il est indiqué
que pour financer son projet elle va
arrêter les financements à la robe elle
arrêtera la contribution à l'Europe
est-ce que vous est-ce que vous
connaissez un club une association qui
compte où vous pouvez y participer mais
vous payez pas la cotisation ça n'est
pas vrai et donc il y a
un moment comme pour reprendre la
formule de Emmanuel Macron il y a
clairement aujourd'hui un projet caché
de sortie donc l'objectif de ce concours
c'est de démonter dites-vous c'est
d'avoir un débat qui soit un débat de
clarté et c'est vrai aussi sur les
retraites et c'est vrai aussi sur
l'environnement songer sur
l'environnement c'est quand même l'un
des principaux défis et je termine
là-dessus l'un des principaux défis de
notre société de la même manière ce même
document que j'évoquais pour financer
son projet
les deux seuls candidats au premier tour
qui parlaient de planification
écologique c'était
Emmanuel Macron encore une question on
va accueillir maintenant
brigitte-gaucher tamtrane mais on les a
tendance j'ai une question sur le
déroulé de la campagne donc elle sera
très différente par ailleurs il a
beaucoup pété un président de la guerre
elle continue en Ukraine elle s'enlise
même est-ce qu'Emmanuel Macron pourrait
aller à Kiev il a toujours dit que il se
rendrait à Kiev le jour où sa visite
serait utile au regard de la situation
internationale il l'a exprimé à
plusieurs reprises et c'est
véritablement sa ligne c'est-à-dire que
le président continuera à s'investir
évidemment pour faire cesser la guerre
en Ukraine
et en parallèle le candidat sera sur le
terrain beaucoup sur le terrain il était
aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit dans les
hauts de France il sera demain dans le
grand test et ils continuera à aller à
la rencontre des Français dans ces 15
jours qui nous sépare du 24
ce sera pas la visite à la Boris Johnson
il a toujours été très clair dessus il
ira le jour où sa visite sera
utile
je vous présente Brigitte boucher de LCP
tam-trans
mesdames justement on va maintenant
s'intéresser au programme il y a
quelques instants Emmanuel Macron a
déclaré on va collectivement améliorer
la réforme des retraites et notamment le
passage à 65 ans qui est un point
saillant du programme du président
candidat et oui ce que vient de dire le
président de la République c'est qu'il
n'exclut pas un référendum sur les
retraites ça pourrait être ça modifié le
projet
il a expliqué plusieurs choses vous
faites un si je peux me permettre un
petit RAC il a expliqué le fait que
utiliser le référendum sur quelques
réformes que ce soit tel furent ces
termes il ne l'excluait pas parce que
c'est un outil à disposition de notre
démocratie qui est importante et
deuxièmement il a exposé la vision de sa
réforme des retraites d'abord mais pour
rester sur le référendum est-ce que
c'est parce qu'aujourd'hui cette mesure
là elle ne fait pas qu'on s'insus donc
il faut demander aux Français de se
prononcer j'en viens justement d'abord
cette réforme c'est une vision et une
méthode et je crois que c'est très
important la vision elle a souvent été
prise comme raccourci en disant ça n'est
pas une vision c'est un âge un départ
plus éloigné c'est pas ça la vision
l'âge
oserais-je dire c'est une modalité qui
résulte d'une vision c'est quoi la
vision c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est on le
sait tous il va nous falloir
progressivement travailler plus
longtemps c'est soit ça soit à la fin
l'arrêt de notre système auquel on est
tant attaché qui a un système de
remercier aujourd'hui c'est le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites vous savez
moi je l'ai vécu je l'ai vécu je l'ai
vécu qu'en 2016 nous faisions le
programme de du quinquennat qui vient de
s'écouler et en 2016 ce fameux corps
nous avait remis une note en nous disant
vous inquiétez pas il ne faut aucune
réforme des retraites parce que tout le
système est financé six mois après j'ai
bien six mois après on recevait du même
organisme un autre rapport qui nous
disait en fait il est pas du tout
financé aujourd'hui
toutes et tous
on le sait si on veut maintenir ce dont
on a
hérité de l'après-guerre c'est-à-dire ce
système par répartition qui est
essentiel parce que c'est l'un des
piliers de notre État providence ou de
notre politique sociale ça n'est pas
vous qui cotisez pour votre propre
retraite en fonction de vos revenus ce
sont des actifs qui financent la
retraite des retraités pour maintenir
cela du fait ne serait-ce que de la
pyramide des âges du fait ne serait-ce
que de l'allongement et
fort heureux de l'allongement de notre
vie et en plus de l'allongement en bonne
santé alors on sait tous est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas travailler progressivement
est-ce qu'il faut tout de suite passer à
65 ans mais c'est exactement la question
qui a posé aujourd'hui le candidat
Emmanuel Macron il a rappelé que sa
vision c'était il fallait sauf à réduire
les pensions sauf à augmenter nos
cotisations est-ce que personne ne
souhaite il fallait qu'on accepte
progressivement travailler tous un peu
plus longtemps deuxième élément et c'est
très important dit il faut prendre en
compte la pénibilité des carrières il
faut arrêter les régimes spéciaux mais
individualiser les pénibilités il faut
très important aussi faire en sorte que
les retraites de plus bas niveau
puissent être augmentés pour que la
carrière complète on est au moins 1100
euros et après il évoque la méthode la
méthode c'est la concertation la méthode
c'est de dire voilà moi j'ai fixé une
vision
il va leur parler de ça les partis
politiques qui ont appelé à voter pour
lui hier soir et il ça va faire partie
des sujets qui seront discutés ensemble
il est il a expliqué très clairement que
voilà le débat démocratique d'une
présidentielle c'est d'exposer des
visions vous avez deux visions qui sur
les retraites de son diamétralement
opposés une vision courageuse mais une
vision de sincérité qui est celle que je
viens d'exposer proposer par le candidat
Emmanuel Macron et qui est ressenti
comme brutal par une partie de la
population d'abord mais j'y viens mais
d'abord faut quand même dire il y a une
vision de sincérité et une vision de
sincérité et sociale pourquoi sincérité
parce que accepter le fait de dire qu'on
va devoir progressivement travailler
tout simplement mais social parce que
notre principal objectif est de
préserver notre système
répartitionaliste et le Parti communiste
qui ont appelé à voter pour Emmanuel
Macron il n'y voit pas du tout une
mesure sociale et de financer en plus
notre modèle social de manière générale
et deuxièmement vous avez aujourd'hui un
projet porté par Marine Le Pen qui
n'est absolument pas financé qui propose
de réduire l'âge 60 ou 62 ans en
fonction des cas de figure
des cas de figure qui un n'est pas
financé et qui de de manière
certainement
retenu 65 ans est-ce que vous pensez pas
que vous allez avoir du mal à élargir
votre socle pour le second tour de
au-delà de cette vision très claire de
vision différente il y a cette
concertation et d'ailleurs le candidat
l'a dit tout à l'heure c'est une
concertation à la fois avec les
syndicats et une concertation à la fois
politique parce que il ne faut pas ou
plutôt si on veut mener de telles
réformes pour notre pays évidemment
qu'il faut le faire avec une méthode qui
soit extrêmement ouverte qui tiennent
compte des avis y compris exprimés par
les Français et qui parce que les
Allemands
on va parler d'autres mesures qui ont
aussi marqué les esprits qui se plaisent
pas du tout pas non plus à gauche c'est
notamment l'idée d'assortir le RSA de
contrepartie est-ce que tout n'est pas
déjà prévu dans la loi il y a déjà des
droits et des devoirs pour les
allocataires du RSA qu'est-ce que vous
prévoyez de plus mais vous savez le RSA
active je n'ai pas d'accord avec vous
enfin pour en avoir beaucoup discuté y
compris avec des personnes que vous avez
indiqué venant de gauche
la réforme de la RSA vous avez deux
réformes vous avez une réforme qui
consisterait à dire je fais je donne le
RSA en contrepartie de conditions
regardez ce que proposait Éric Zemmour
qui en était la quintessence on a
l'impression que c'était des travaux
forcés si vous étiez au RSA c'est pas ça
que vous proposez de la formation c'est
pas du tout ça qu'on propose qu'est-ce
qu'on propose aujourd'hui vous avez un
état de fait quand vous voyez que vous
pouvez rester au RSA plusieurs années
que généralement une personne sur deux
resta il reste plus de 4 ans est-ce
qu'on peut se satisfaire de ça à
l'évidence non et quel est le problème
c'est que le RSA
qui est l'ancêtre qui est le nouveau nom
du RMI fondé par Michel Rocard avec ce
mot de l'insertion le mot insertion au
fur et à mesure des années était oubliée
pas de la locataire d'ailleurs d'abord
de la puissance publique
on a failli sur l'accompagnement donc
qu'est-ce qu'il y a exactement mais donc
c'était déjà dans la loi
non on peut avoir les discussions très
techniques ce qui existait fut un temps
c'est que les départements qui avaient
cette compétence d'insertion fut un
temps souvenez-vous ils avaient un
montant minimum à dédié un insertion
chaque année qui au fur et à mesure des
années cette obligation a disparu nous
agences de l'État d'obligation pour les
départements ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que dès lors que vous êtes en capacité
vous avez des situations individuelles
qui doivent être prises en compte je
pense à une femme à la tête d'une
famille monoparentale qui n'aura pas
forcément la capacité le temps
disponible donc vous avez ces situations
individuelles qui doivent être prises en
compte d'une part et d'autre part de
faire ce pacte social qui consiste à
dire dès lors que vous en avez la
possibilité vous devez rentrer dans ces
parcours d'insertion et de l'autre côté
l'État dans sa globalité à l'échelon
national et dans les collectivités
locales à l'obligation de proposer
est-ce que c'est politique finalement
lorsqu'on a dit à sortir le RSA de
contrepartie est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
aller sur le terrain de la droite on a
entendu tous ce que pour dire vraiment
obligatoire mais je vois pas en quoi on
peut tout réformer peut-être vu à l'aune
de est-ce que c'est à gauche est-ce que
c'est à droite moi je demande est-ce que
c'est bon pour résoudre une situation
qui est une situation où vous avez une
personne sur deux qui au bout de quatre
ans reste au RSA je vous réponds oui ce
qui m'importe c'est le devenir de ces
personnes ce qui m'importe c'est de
lutter contre des personnes qui se
retrouvent très bien ce qu'on veut
politique qui a un arrière-plan
idéologique qui consiste à considérer à
considérer que tout revenu d'assistance
est un revenu finalement presque perdu
je vous dis que c'est ce qu'on prenne
vous pouvez pas dire ça a été retenu
vous pouvez pas dire ça c'est pas vrai
c'est pas vrai
[Musique]
par contre oui il y a une vision
politique mais qui est ancré dans toute
décision que nous prenons qui est quand
vous vivez en société vous avez des
droits et des devoirs ça c'est sûr mais
ça c'est vrai pour toutes les mesures
que nous faisons pour toutes les mesures
que nous faisons une autre mesure qui
abrac à gauche c'est rémunéré les
enseignants au mérite c'est-à-dire si
remplacent leurs collègues absents s'ils
font de l'aide aux devoirs est-ce que
vous les prenez pour des fainéants c'est
comme ça que ça a été ressenti les
enseignants se sont sentis stigmatisés à
travers cette proposition qu'est-ce que
vous leur répondez d'abord d'abord
reprenez pas un bout de phrase ou un
élément regardez exactement ce qu'on
propose sur l'école c'est pas ça qu'on
propose c'est pas c'est en aucun cas
résumé comme vous l'avez comme vous
l'avez dit mais ce qu'on propose sur
l'école c'est plusieurs choses c'est
d'abord et je pense que tout le monde
peut le reconnaître quand vous avez des
tâches additionnelles c'est quand même
la moindre des choses d'être rémunéré
pour cette tâches additionnelles
aujourd'hui vous avez plein de profs y
compris pendant la période de la covid
qui ont fait ces tâches additionnelles
qui ont travaillé plus qu'il ne
travaillait jusqu'à présent c'est quand
même assez normal de pouvoir les
rémunérer plus premier point deuxième
point c'est comment on donne plus de
liberté dans l'organisation de notre
école au niveau local avec un exemple
très concret c'est ce qu'on a fait à
Marseille parce que il est pas vrai de
dire que la façon qu'on a d'accompagner
nos jeunes et partout la même surcroît
certains craignent une privatisation de
l'école c'est ce qu'ils entendent contre
leur dit autonomie mais comment vous
pouvez dire des trucs pareils
les enseignants
elle est où la privatisation je vois pas
le début du commencement il est
qu'est-ce qui pourrait vous laisser
penser qu'il y a le début du
commencement d'une privatisation
et c'est une privatisation que de dire
que si à l'échelle d'une école vous
laissez plus de liberté au corps
enseignant à la direction
j'ai quatre enfants le fait que dans une
école une direction d'école en lien avec
le corps enseignant en lien avec les
parents d'élèves puissent se dire le
projet pédagogique au sens là au sens
large de notre école
tenant compte aussi des spécificités du
territoire on pense qu'il faudrait le
faire de manière pertinente comme ça bon
je trouve ça profondément pertinent
encore une fois dans la concertation
ensuite vous avez un cas qui est on
recrute les professeurs pour les porter
ce projet pédagogique comme la liberté
du professeur de dire ben moi je me sens
à l'aise ou je ne me sens pas à l'aise
c'est quand même dans ce cas-là
qui doit être la même pour tous et c'est
la dernière question de la ville je suis
aujourd'hui ministre de l'Agriculture je
peux vous dire que
les situations sont quand même très
diverses dans notre territoire et que
croire que la même solution doit être
apportée partout sur le territoire sans
prendre en compte tes spécificités de
nos territoires et bien ça n'est pas de
bonne politique de prendre en compte des
spécificités comme nous l'avons fait à
Marseille là c'est de la bonne politique
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'intelligence
collective de savoir s'adapter de savoir
s'adapter
absolument pas merci beaucoup Brigitte
et est en train de oui mais bien sûr je
viens de Normandie qui a la passion la
prime Macron qu'on va multiplier et on
va gagner
le versement des des dividendes au
versement soit de l'intéressement soit
de la prime Macron et c'est une grande
mesure
qui va venir vous rejoindre elle va
devenir obligatoire oui ce qu'on va
faire c'est que ce qu'on propose de
faire c'est qu'aujourd'hui ce qui n'est
ce qui est absolument insupportable
c'est quand une entreprise crée de la
valeur et vers dividendes à ces
actionnaires que dans le même moment
elle n’intéresse pas les salariés
évidemment si jamais vous avez dans tous
les cas vous avez la possibilité de
verser la prime Macron mais si demain
vous versez des dividendes à ce
moment-là versement des dividendes doit
être conditionné soit un accord
d'intéressement soit un accord de
participation soit au versement de la
prime Macron et je trouve que c'est
véritablement aussi redonné ce sens à ce
collectif qui est une entreprise quand
vous créez de la richesse et que
l'actionnaire se sert des dividendes il
est bien normal pardon de rémunérer
aussi les salariés vous le connaissez
directeur adjoint de la rédaction du
Figaro c'est à vous aussi
alors on va parler politique avec les
jours qui nous séparent du deuxième tour
et puis des événements qui vous nous
interpellent par exemple Jean-François
Copé pas plus tard qu'aujourd'hui dit et
bien j'appelle le gouvernement j'appelle
le président Macron a passé un pacte
gouvernement avec la droite de
gouvernement Jean-François Copé qui n'a
jamais dit vraiment beaucoup de mal du
gouvernement il faut le dire d'autres
sont dans le même état d'esprit
qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez nous
notre ADN a toujours été le dépassement
regardez ce qu'a fait Eric verte
Eric verte qui a rejoint depuis
maintenant de nombreuses semaines la
candidature d'Emmanuel Macron et ce qui
est vrai pour la droite de gouvernement
est aussi pour la gauche notre ADN a
toujours été se dépassement toutes
celles et ceux qui croient dans ce
projet et encore une fois quand on croit
dans un projet ça veut pas dire qu'on
croit dans l'entièreté des dispositions
que contient ce projet qu'on se retrouve
on se retrouve dans l'essentiel ben
notre responsabilité commune mais je le
redis que ce soit de droite ou de gauche
ou de gauche c'est de toujours
poursuivre ce dépassement
de mariage après moi je pense que ça
n'est pas le côté boutiquier
qui qui doit l'emporter sur surtout
cette vision du déplacement dès lors que
vous passez d'une vision qui est on
rassemble donc qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à Jean-François Copé que le que
le match je réponds que c'était très
touché que il considère que dans des
considère que nous puissions se
retrouver sur un certain nombre de
points et j'invite et je le redis il y a
pas des personnes il y a personne de
gauche de le faire il y a pas il y a pas
une entrée au club c'est en disant
c'est pas c'est pas et ça j'insiste
dessus d'aucune manière que ce soit
d'accord il ne doit y avoir ignorer des
accords d'appareil c'est pas ça le sujet
le sujet c'est de se rassembler sur une
vision politique on peut ne pas être
d'accord surtout mais on est d'accord
sur l'essentiel et si c'est Monsieur
Nicolas Sarkozy ancien président de la
République qui vous le demande qu'il
demande aux personnes je suis pas sûr
qu'il m'appelle
vous connaissez maintenant j'ai
énormément de respect pour le président
Nicolas Sarkozy et Sarkozy pardon et là
aussi je pense que toute personne se
retrouve sur ce projet en demandant et
en proposant d'avancer sur ce projet
doivent être
accueillis parce que c'est notre ADN
même mais je le redis que ce soit la
droite ou la gauche alors je pense par
exemple que pendant toute cette campagne
nous avons pas du tout suffisamment
parler d'environnement pas du tout alors
justement conduisez en parlant
d'environnement donc un peu quand même
d'une politique qui pourrait être une
politique écologique de gauche et quand
on regarde le résultat des scrutins
d'hier on se dit peut-être que le
président sortant aurait intérêt à aller
un peu sur les les marges de la gauche
avec un électorat écologique qu'il faut
séduire avec l'électorat même de
Monsieur Mélenchon qui a un grand
discours sur l'écologie qu'est-ce que
vous allez faire là moi je pense que
vous êtes faible sur ce front là je suis
pas sûr que que nous soyons faibles que
soient d'ailleurs sur le bilan ou sur
surtout sur ce que nous proposons en
revanche non je suis sûr
que c'est un sujet qui a été totalement
absente ces derniers mois pour plusieurs
raisons Elisabeth Martichoux le disait
tout à l'heure
vous l'avez suivi ces derniers mois ont
été profondément marqués par la guerre
en Ukraine et donc derrière le paravent
non plus non enfin ils n'empêche que des
débats comme les débats sur l'écologie
n'ont pas eu lieu ou pas suffisamment eu
lieu avait une partie écologique
finalement bien sûr notamment on peut en
parler des heures ce cette vision auquel
je suis autant attaché qui s'appelle une
seule santé de dire que la santé humaine
animale ou environnementale en fait elle
ne fait qu'une mais pour revenir sur
l'environnement qui sait aujourd'hui par
exemple que dans trois minutes que dans
le projet qui que nous proposons aux
Français dans le projet que nous
proposons l'objectif c'est d'aller
encore deux fois plus vite sur la
réduction des gaz à effet de serre que
nous l'avons fait dans ce quinquennat
qui lui-même allait déjà deux fois plus
vite que le quinquennat précédent nous
n'en n'avons pas parlé tout à l'heure on
évoquait la planification
environnementale terme utiliser
uniquement par deux candidats Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et Emmanuel
macronologique vous répondez à ma
question vous allez vous tourner un peu
vers la gauche
notre objectif c'est de rassembler plus
les mots planifiés
il y a deux points très importants
politiquesment d'abord un mais vous nous
suivez depuis fort longtemps et vous le
savez bien notre ADN c'est de rassembler
et se dépasser se dépassement il est au
cœur de tout ce qu'on a conçu tout donc
on continuera à le faire à droite et à
gauche et le deuxième volet c'est qu'il
faut entendre le message des Français
hier soir il y a quand même 25%
d'absence sionistes Jean-Luc Mélenchon
fait plus de 22% et vous avez l'extrême
droite qui est à 23%. donc il faut
entendre ce message vous le traduisez en
un mot comment les avancées qu'on doit
faire sur le changement climatique et
l'écologie est très importante vous avez
hier des millions de Français qui ont
envoyé un signal très clair en disant ça
doit être une priorité du prochain
extrême droite ça veut dire que
Mélenchon extrême gauche ou pas
la grande différence entre Madame Le Pen
et Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est qu'avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon on partage des
valeurs là ou avec Madame Le Pen je ne
partage pas de valeur même quand il
manifeste avec les islamoschistes ça
veut pas dire qu'on a pas des énormes
différents et j'ai eu à titre personnel
de nombreuses passes d'armes avec lui
mais on partage un certain nombre de
valeurs on partage des combats en commun
comme sur l'environnement
l'environnement pour terminer là-dessus
vous savez je le disais tout à l'heure
Madame Le Pen ne croit pas dans
l'environnement elle n'y croit pas elle
réduit les budgets dédiés à
l'environnement elle balaye d'un revers
de la main tout ce que nous prévoyons
sur le changement climatique
ça ne fait pas en tant que tel une
politique pour diminuer les gaz à effet
de serre elle n'y croit pas
elle elle repousse à plus tard pourquoi
parce qu'il faut affronter cette
complexité avoir le courage de mener la
bataille Jean-Luc Mélenchon lui il
aborde ce sujet nous nous abordons
sujets on peut se retrouver sur de tels
thématiques c'est terminé merci beaucoup
c'est gagné c'est gagné ou pas rien
n'est joué et ce sera serré
je peux vous dire
je me suis dit qu'il y avait une de
manière factuelle un point positif qui
est que le président Emmanuel Macron
hier soir a fait plus de voix que son
score de 2017 c'est quand même un
événement surtout après le positif et ça
c'est positif c'est après le quinquennat
que nous avons passé après les crises
auxquelles nous avons dû faire face au
même moment ce que je vous disais 25% de
nos compatriotes ne sont pas allés voter
et l'extrême droite est toujours très
haute dans notre pays et donc voilà
rien rien n'est joué et il faut
absolument continuer à se battre merci
beaucoup
défendre pied à pied quelques éléments
de programme dont vous souhaitez qu'il
soit clarifié parce que pour vous il y a
certains malentendus il y a un reste
quoi une petite dizaine de jours une
grosse dizaine de jours pour convaincre
Merci à VOUS Julien de Normandie merci
et on passe à la deuxième partie de
[Musique]
bonjour journal La Capelle qui
s'installe à l'instant c'est la loi du
genre c'est la deuxième partie de
l'émission merci d'être avec nous Jean
de La Capelle vous êtes porte parole de
Marine Le Pen vous représentez la
candidate Marine Le Pen qualifiée depuis
hier soir vous êtes député
européen merci Marine Le Pen qui pour
cette première journée
a semblé prendre son temps en tout cas
elle est allé à son QG et puis elle a
fait un déplacement dans l'Yonne elle a
pour reprendre son expression fétiche
affiché depuis des semaines et des
semaines de campagne le calme des
vieilles troupes elle va rester dans ce
registre là pendant les 15 jours qui
viennent oui parce que ça lui a réussi
elle n'a pas souhaité enjamber la
campagne des premiers Dour parce qu'elle
n'a pas fait son adversaire email Macron
dont on peut se rappeler tout de même
qu'il a tout fait pour annoncer sa
nature le plus tard possible je dirais
même à la dernière minute et puis qui a
souvent prétexté notamment la
terrible guerre en Ukraine pour essayer
de s'extirper un petit peu de ce débat
démocratique que les Français
attendaient lors du premier tour peu
importe les choses aujourd'hui ont
évolué le premier tour est passé et donc
enfin Emmanuel Macron est un campagne il
était à donner en effet comme vous le
disiez nous attendions impatiemment
qu'il aille sur le terrain Marine Le Pen
elle l'a pas attendu parce que vous le
savez depuis 7 mois et sur le terrain et
s'il y a d'outre-mer les sillonne les
différentes régions françaises et je
crois que c'est aussi un des points
forts de de sa candidature si cette
proximité qu'avec le peuple français qui
elle a pu l'occasion de présenter son
projet présidentiel depuis de nombreux
mois on a dit plutôt il a été dit et
répété qu'elle avait fait une bonne
campagne à la survécu à l'offensive
Zemmour à la survécu à toutes les
trahisons qui auraient pu l'affaiblir
elle termine avec un score supérieur en
2017 vous l'avez dit Emmanuel Macron lui
a à peine fait campagne et il termine
plus haut qui ne l'était en 2017 est-ce
que ça vous a surpris qu'il arrive à
compt utiliser sur son bilan au premier
tour plus de 27 et demi pour cent des
voies des Français
il termine plus en effet avec un
effondrement total de des République et
vous mettez un autre candidat peut-être
chez un publicain avec un projet
peut-être que ça modifie le scénario on
peut aussi
si on est dans le jeu des projections on
pourrait se dire si la candidature
d'Éric Zemmour n'avait pas été présente
Marine Le Pen a été devant probablement
à l'issue du premier tour donc mais avec
campagne donc
cependant nous sommes enfin les deux
candidats parce que finalement les
sondages depuis quand même un certain
nombre de temps pronostiqué les deux
candidats email Macron et Marine Le Pen
sont au second tour ce qui démontre une
nouvelle fois c'est que le clivage
droite n'existe plus et ça fait
plusieurs fois que nous la lisons comme
ça en 2017 ça va déjà été une première
illustration en 2019 lors des élections
européennes également c'est inscrit
international et le Astron national
avait gagné cette élection avec la
République en marche qui est juste
derrière nous et là une fois de plus les
Français ont choisi un clivage qui est
totalement différent je crois qui
s'incarne autour des mondialistes
derrière l'image d'Emmanuel Macron et
puis les patriotes c'est comme ça qu'on
peut les derrière Marine Le Pen je crois
que c'est celle-là non plus ne pas citer
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui d'ailleurs était
pas du tout loin de vous mais c'est la
gauche la gauche n'a pas disparu c'est
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui l'incarne
il y a des mondialistes il y a des gens
qui de son combat dans notre projet qui
peuvent se retrouver peut-être dans le
projet d'Emmanuel Macron mais je crois
qu'il y a aussi des patriotes est-ce que
vous avez de commun avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et surtout ces électeurs
la France insoumise est probablement
scindée en deux en deux parties Yann
électorat qui est finalement à l'image
de leur leader très pro immigration
c'est ce qu'on appelle le service à
moghoschisme très prowocythme qui est
très pro clandestin qui est anti flic il
faut languette aussi et puis il y a une
classe
ou une catégorie aussi d'électeurs chez
Jean-Louis mergeon beaucoup plus
populaire et qui se rapproche peut-être
de l'ancienne l'ancien Parti communiste
qui a disparu et dont on avait récupéré
un certain nombre de électorat parce que
je crois que nous avons dans notre
colonne vertébrale des sujets qui sont
parmi nous fondamentaux autour de
l'immigration autour de l'insécurité
notamment autour de la sécurité plutôt
et mais également un un projet social
puisque vous le savez elle a parlé de
fracture sociale même hier Marine Le Pen
mais Jean-Luc Mélenchon il y a quand
même répété trois quatre fois hier passe
une voie ne doit aller à Marine Le Pen
c'est un coup dur pour vous non parce
que je crois que
ça fait bien longtemps que les consignes
de vote ne sont plus appliquées
finalement que les électeurs
n'appartiennent à personne et que les
électeurs ont cette liberté
de pouvoir se reporter s'abstenir ou non
et d'ailleurs les projections que les
différents institutions d'âge démontrent
je regardais encore une projection sur
lectorat de Monsieur Mélenchon il y a
un tiers qui pourrait se
voir
le retenir oui mais vous savez je crois
que les gens comment on peut parler mais
c'est ici je crois que je crois que
enfin le choix il est très clair c'est
il faut être clair illustration c'est le
programme notamment de réforme des
retraites d'Emmanuel Macron mais vous
savez si on a même Macron je viens de
l'écouter sur un de vos confrères il l'a
confirmé le projet de retraite ce sera
une réforme à l'âge de 65 ans donc il
faut travailler plus pour gagner moins
parce qu'on sait aussi que le calcul des
retraites se fera sur l'ensemble de la
carrière et effectivement mon confrère
tout ça lui a dit ça peut être 64 on
verra on va en discuter ça c'est le vous
connaissez c'est l'homme de
communication Emmanuel Macron c'est
l'homme de communication email Macron il
dit d'ailleurs dans cet entretien il dit
je ne suis pas un comédien où je suis
pas un magicien d'ailleurs c'est ça que
je voulais dire je faisais un musicien
mais on le sait très comédien il nous
dit jeune ne souhaite pas diviser les
Français il a quand même passé son temps
à diviser les Français sur le dernier
quinquennat et il parle même d'un
référendum qui pourrait soumettre aux
Français pour leur proposer ce projet de
réforme nous savons tous aussi de la
manipulation il avait promis la
proportionnelle puisqu'on parle de
démocratie il avait promis la
proportionnelle dans son programme avant
d'être élu il l'avait repromi
à l'issue du mouvement des gilets jaunes
rien n'était fait en homme et il a trahi
là aussi sa promesse
on va parler de votre programme dans un
instant avec Brigitte Boucher est en
train de nuit qui vont nous rejoindre
est-ce que vous redoutez la
redyabolisation dans cette entre deux
tours maintenant que vous n'avez plus
finalement comme paravent Éric Zemmour
qui a pris beaucoup lui dans les excès
effectivement
antimigration antimigration etc je ne
crois pas je ne crois pas parce que
certains ici encore de qualifiés
d'extrême droite je me suis jamais moi
je me jamais senti dans un mouvement qui
était d'extrême droite j'entends et je
souris d'ailleurs
français et vous savez qu'est-ce qu'il y
avait écrit ce slogan ou qui avait écrit
un livre qui déclinait cette philosophie
c'était Samuel machal en 1998 voyez donc
je suis moins un vieux militant je suis
arrivé il y a 37 ans dans ce mouvement
et j'y arrivais parce que j'ai toujours
aimé cette globalité dans son programme
c'est ce que Marine d'ailleurs propose à
travers un slogan qui depuis maintenant
et reconnu par les Français c'est rendre
au français leur pays leur argent leur
pays ça veut dire bien sûr contre les
immigration régler les problèmes de
sécurité et rendre au Frontier leur
argent ça veut dire bien sûr pouvoir
régler le problème de pouvoir d'achat et
c'est elle qui en septembre c'est elle
qui aime le pouvoir d'achat au cœur des
débats elle avait été très visionnaire
vous disiez on n'a pas trembler pendant
lesquels ici qui ont traversé le
mouvement mais là aussi c'est votre
évisionnaire qui fait d'elle je crois
que j'ai d'État sur votre programme
Brigitte boucher vous parlez immigration
justement hier Emmanuel Macron a dit
parlant de vous vouloir je cite lutter
contre l'international des populistes et
des xénophobes si on regarde votre
programme a-t-il vraiment tort notamment
quand on regarde le référendum pour
empêcher l'immigration de modifier la
composition et l'identité française
c'est bien l'une de vos propositions
est-ce que ce n'est pas antimigri est-ce
que ce n'est pas anti étranger ce que
dit Emmanuel Macron est de la
diffamation ou de la manipulation il y a
pas une mesure dans le programme de
Marine Le Pen et notamment son projet de
loi il y a l'immigration il n'y a pas
une mesure qui est conditionnée à
l'origine à la couleur de peau à la
religion il y a pas une seule mesure qui
est liée cela cependant elle souhaite
dans ce référendum qu'elle va soumettre
aux Français elle souhaite réintégrer la
priorité nationale bien de racisme dans
la présentationale Steve privilégiez les
Français et prioriser les Français cette
information j'ai un vrai problème en
effet avec cette sémantique là je
rappelle que la préférence nationale
elle a été en 1934 appliquée par Roger
Salengro il était ministre socialiste et
pendant des années on a vécu avec ses
préférences nationales d'ailleurs il
existe il y a encore pas si longtemps
que cela dans une partie de la fonction
publique donc il n'y a rien il n'y a
rien à racisme dans le premier national
la fin du regroupement familial les
prestations sociales réservées aux seuls
familles françaises
l'emploi nous c'est Madame c'est
appliqué ce que font 80 % des pays dans
le monde parce que vous croyez les
Japonais ou les Canadiens les
Australiens ne privilégient pas leur
propre peuples c'est quand même anti
étranger anti-migration
c'est pas rejeté l'autre ou l'étranger
c'est privilégié d'abord les Français je
crois qu'aujourd'hui quand on a 6
millions de chômeurs 6,7 millions de
chômeurs et quand on a 10 millions de
pauvres ça date 10 millions de personnes
qui veillent moins de 1000 euros par
mois je crois qu'il me paraît normal
d'avoir un projet qui privilégie au jour
les Français on a plus les moyens
financiers matériels pour accueillir
toute la misère du monde la question
c'est que vous l'avez dit Valérie Le Pen
elle a voulu se montrer comme une
candidate rassembleuse or des parties un
visage adouci elle a été aidée en cela
notamment avec la candidature d'Éric
Zemmour est-ce que tout ça c'est pas que
de la com si on regarde le fond de votre
programme et notamment sur l'immigration
non mais Le Pen est resté fidèle assez
fondamentaux elle est restée fidèle à à
nos orientations elle a souhaité ne plus
faire dans l'autre anse le trans moi ça
me rappelle en effet les premières
années de notre mouvement politique il y
a eu de l'outrance mais
il y a de trans chez le trans clairement
je suis concurrent que vous citiez et
c'est peut-être pour ça d'ailleurs que
il termine à 7%. et qui appelle pour
vous mais c'est très bien écoutez vous
avez au premier tour on choisit
Marine Le Pen installation est
extrêmement claire que tous les
patriotes
qui sont de droite de gauche ou du
centre
s'ils se reconnaissent dans notre projet
qui viennent de rejoindre s'ils veulent
surtout que ce quinquennat se termine
définitivement s'ils veulent pour
licencier mais le Macron aussi belle que
son constat cette casse sociale qu'on
stoppe sur raquette fiscal si lol qu'on
stoppe cette fracture sociale parce que
depuis 5 ans jamais le pays était autant
divisé jamais le pays a été mépriser par
un président de la République et jamais
d'ailleurs un président de la Belgique a
cité autour de moi
il dit que vous soutient mais il y aura
pas d'alliance il y aura il y aura pas
de meeting commun
il y aura des négociations pour les
législatives je vous le dis vous savez
je sors du bureau de campagne vous étiez
aujourd'hui mais il a pas voulu on n'a
pas attendu sur votre campagne pour
prendre ses décisions là l'élection
présidentielle c'est la rencontre d'un
homme ou d'une femme avec le peuple
français donc il y a pas de d'alliance à
voir mais pas de grandes réconciliation
elle a gagné donc ce premier tour
ecoutez maintenant que tous ceux qui
veulent nous rejoindre et j'espère
qu'ils seront nombreux mais on le voit
dans les sondages on le voit bien que
avec la marche d'erreur on est sur une
égalité avec un nom de Macron c'est là
qu'il y a un scénario qui est très
différente par rapport 2017 moi je pense
que nous gagnerons cette élection
présidentielle le 24 avril c'est drôle
c'est qu'elle veut faire un gouvernement
de l'Union nationale à l'exception
d'Éric Zemmour c'est à dire que elle
veut rassembler très largement mais pas
ceux qui pensent un peu comme elle non
mais pièce il y a effectivement pour
Marine Le Pen elle constituera son
gouvernement quand
il sera d'actualité voilà elle choisira
un premier ministre la constituera
gouvernement qui sera le gouvernement
d'union nationale elle le dit je crois
qu'il y a des gens avec lesquels je peux
me retrouver à la cité
de manière anecdotique parce que en
effet sur son souhait de retrouver
c'est Marine Le Pen qui est au second
tour c'est Marine Le Pen qui le choix à
la fois de la direction qu'il faut
prendre et je crois qu'aujourd'hui elle
a démontré qu'elle est capable
d'ailleurs les sondages le disent
qu'elle est capable de rassembler 50%
des français ça sera déjà alors on va
parler du projet l'Europe parce que vous
avez un peu changé de stratégie sur
l'Europe depuis 2017 vous voulez moins
contribuer à l'Europe mais restez dans
l'Union vous croyez que les autres pays
vont vous dire oui vous vous donnez un
blanc sain là dessus
je crois que oui je crois quand vous
êtes le deuxième pays contributeur quand
vous êtes solidarité
il y a pas de raison qu'on soit toujours
dans l'excédent quelque sorte qu'on
donne plus que on ne reçoivent
Marine Le Pen je crois que c'est une
chance si elle gagne parce que cette
Europe depuis 30 ans elle nous a été
vendu comme une Europe capable de nous
protéger de protéger nos emplois de
protéger les entreprises de protéger nos
frontières de protéger nos idées rien
avec des protéger sur le sanitaire elle
nous a pas protégé non
plus
je suis député européen et je suis
membre de la commission marché intérieur
nous avons été les derniers avant les
vaccins vous savez pourquoi parce que
les négociateurs qui sont des gens même
pas élus dont on n'a jamais eu la liste
définitive on voulait négocier et
acheter le vaccin le moins cher possible
bilan les Américains les Britanniques
l'ensemble du monde
la campagne de vaccination a mal démarré
elle s'est elle mais après elle sait
très bien et beaucoup
bien plus rapidement qu'en Allemagne
absolument
si ensuite on a on a on a pu déployer le
stratégie de vaccination très bien
qu'est-ce qui a aidé aussi est-ce que
les Français soient quasiment tous
vaccinés c'est le passe d'une part
sanitaire puis le vaccinal sans cela je
crois qu'il y avait une réticence et on
nous aurons pas eu le même taux de
vaccination moi ce que je constate c'est
que l'Europe nous a pas favorisé le
mouvement de la division et puis
dernière chose puisque on n'est pas de
masque on n'est pas le matériel de test
c'était quand même la catastrophe
excusez-moi on a aucune souveraineté
médicale ou sanitaire rabais sur la
Pâques pour les agriculteurs pour verser
directement de l'aide aux agriculteurs
vous sortez de la Pâques on modifie la
pas qu'il y a une partie des aides qui
seront directement distribuées selon
selon en fait la la priorité ou la
stratégie que nous aurons à définir par
rapport et comment vous comment vous
imposer des changements de règles tout à
l'heure je viens de Normandie disait
c'est comme quand on a on AD club et ben
le RN il veut plus payer sa cotisation
vous croyez que le club va continuer à
vous accepter moi je pense que l'Union
européenne est en danger on le voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui
il y avait je vois mal quand même que
les Britanniques en sont partis c'était
comme une grande puissance on fait
partie parce que parce que la méthode
parce que les moyens parce que la
manière et la méthodologie en effet de
l'Union européenne est extrêmement
autoritaire le l'Union européenne et
c'est de
gouverner de manière fédérale et des
harmoniser le jeu on ne pourra pas on ne
pourra pas créer 27 membres et
d'ailleurs plus urbaine cherche en plus
engager
son scope je crois qu'on y arrivera pas
je crois que nous sommes plutôt
n'a pas été élu qui doit d'abord
demander son avis à l'ensemble des
nations se permet quelque chose qu'elle
devrait pas faire elle se prend pour une
présidente des États-Unis d'Europe elle
ne l'est pas donc ça ça pose un vrai
problème d'abord de légitimité
comme la Macédoine
justement
pas digéré les 27 pays mais revient sur
votre question quand même initiale nous
souhaitons une grande Europe parce que
nous sommes pro européen la Grande
Europe elle part pas une grande Europe
de coopération la Grande Europe des
nations c'est d'ailleurs que le général
de Gaulle volley je pense que Ariane
Airbus sont deux exemples emblématiques
de la réussite européenne on ne pourra
pas on ne pourra pas via l'Europe
réussir l'ensemble des défis bien
évidemment et vous rejetez ce qui vous
plaît c'est l'Europe à la carte la
France des années de négocier l'Europe
oui moi je pense que je pense que quand
l'Europe nous avait dit qu'elle nous
protégerait de l'immigration et qu'elle
ne le fait pas je crois que ça me pose
un vrai problème comme le la
Grande-Bretagne est sorti l'Union
européenne européenne n'y croyons pas
nous le dirions vous savez
2017 je sais pas si vous avez suivi
l'actualité et vous avez suivi Marine Le
Pen a notamment avec un syndrome de ses
alliés en Belgique en Allemagne en
Pologne en Hongrie en Espagne en Italie
s'est réuni une première fois var
si mes souvenirs sont bons et une
deuxième fois à Madrid dernièrement avec
l'ensemble de ses alliés et il souhaite
demain constituer un nouveau groupe au
sein du Parlement européen on attendait
la victoire de Victor Hormann elle a eu
aussi ce groupe a lieu nous serons le
premier groupe de position au
seigneurnes et là nous changerons les
choses parce que je crois qu'on peut
changer les choses de l'intérieur et
qu'on peut redonner un rayonnement une
souveraineté une indépendance et une
liberté notamment sur les gafam c'est un
sujet aussi dont moi je m'occupe au
niveau du Parlement européen mais nous
sommes commémoré entre le géant chinois
et entre les Américains on a un problème
de confidentialité un problème de
liberté un problème de fiscalité
mais vous avez parlé de la guerre en
Ukraine est-ce que vous voulez est-ce
que dès que Marine Le Pen était lui vous
désolidarisez du paquet de sanctions à
l'égard de la réussite de la Russie qui
a été décidé par l'Union européenne non
Marine Le Pen l'a dit cela dépend de ça
dans un sanctions d'abord à la condamné
l'invasion de
l'Ukraine par là aussi clairement
deuxièmement c'est scandalisé comme
l'ensemble de de de l'opinion
internationale sur les drames et sur les
massacres
sur les sanctions ben écoutez je crois
que quand
il y a des sanctions total si elles
impactent le pouvoir d'achat des
Français et les sanctions qui ne
semblent pas qui ne sont pas utiles donc
qu'on appuie sur les oligares qu'on
appuie sur Poutine qu'on appuie sur les
dirigeants qui entourent l'annulaire
Poutine bah ils n'ont pas l'a demandé
notamment ce serait bien que l'ensemble
des producteurs de pétrole baisse leur
prix moyen du pétrole de manière cassée
le prix du marché et de manière impacter
la Russie directement ça ce serait une
sanction intéressante en revanche on va
vous demander aux entreprises françaises
par exemple quand monsieur zellens qui
demande aux entreprises françaises de
quitter la Russie alors que lui-même
tous les jours continuent encore à
profiter par le gazoduc quand même d'un
produit financier important je trouve
pas ça tout à fait équilibré
résistent très bien parce que elle
protège son peuple elle protège son
économie et quand elle continue
finalement c'est flux sur les produits
agiles la Russie je crois qu'elle sait
voilà elle s'équilibrée le le Bien et le
Mal autre mesure que vous prévoyez
sortir du commandement intégré de l'OTAN
est-ce que dans la situation actuelle
vous maintenez ce projet
de le faire je le ferai quand vous
sortiez en une zone conflictuelle parce
que voilà c'est pas dans ces moments là
que on prend ce type de décision mais
c'est le
que ça a une utilité c'est parce que
c'est pas le c'est pas un Sud
d'actualité quand on a aux portes de
l'Europe une guerre je crois qu'il faut
d'abord s'employer sur des priorités et
la priorité c'est de trouver une voie
diplomatique pour essayer de rester dans
votre programme qu'est-ce que ça
changerait de sortir du du commandement
intégré de l'OTAN pourquoi pas sortir de
l'OTAN qu'est-ce que c'est la différence
dans dans le commandement de l'OTAN en
fait c'est la question je peux vous
l'envoyer c'est rien du tout en fait
donc Marine Le Pen ou à la souhaite se
dénouer de cette obligation et de ce que
moi intégré je crois qu'elle a fait
longtemps qu'elle l'avait dit elle le
fera au bon moment et reste une minute
Brigitte une question sur le voile
Marine Le Pen qui veut l'interdire dans
l'espace public à quel titre nom de quoi
parce que c'est un outil politique elle
l'a dit le voile islamique nous allons
les différences entre le musulman les
musulmans il y en a près de 7 millions
je crois en France et l'islamisme
merdical
musulmanes et un voile Disney radical
les amusements radicales utilisent très
souvent le voile comme un outil
politique
de la même manière qu'il revendique un
certain nombre de de des horaires
quelquefois dans les dans les piscines
le fait que il y a une séparation entre
hommes et femmes
parce que là vous sous-entendez que le
voile est forcément un homme
musulmanes sont la plupart du temps
modérés croyez-moi et on le voit
d'ailleurs vous avez très peu de femmes
voilées celles qui sont voilées souvent
sont dans une catégorie de l'islamisme
verticale aujourd'hui nous voulons la
réalité
se battre contre l'islamisme ça veut
dire ça veut dire rompre ça veut dire ça
veut dire d'avoir protéger la cité ça
veut dire ronde tous ces signes
extérieurs qui sont des signes religieux
au-delà des sérieux qui sont des signes
qui sont des signes politiques et je
rappellerai la même manière que il
faudra aussi par exemple les les
fichiers systémiques il faudra savoir
renvoyer chez eux ceux qui sont vous
savez
la mosquée radicale promesse qui est
faite non plus merci beaucoup Brigitte
Etam save qui va vous rejoindre
maintenant pour des questions politiques
reprenez votre souffle
juste une question le débat de
l'entre-deux tours il va être dur là
je crois que Marine Le Pen va réussir ce
débat
d'une part parce que Marine Le Pen est
le même
elle a beaucoup mûri beaucoup changé
depuis 5 ans je crois que si elle est
qualifiée au second tour c'est parce que
elle a gagné par sa personnalité
je crois que les gens ont besoin dans la
personnalité d'un chef d'État potentiel
ils ont besoin de sentir de la solidité
la démontrer qu'elle était solide
notamment dans les quelques événements
compléter traverser le mouvement elle a
gagné je crois aussi en crédibilité dans
son programme et enfin elle a elle est
je crois la candidate de la proximité
depuis 7 mois elle a été rencontrée le
peuple français en outre-mer comme un
métropole je pense que ça c'est ce qui
mène Macron n'a pas et je suis convaincu
que dans le débat elle sera le maître en
valeur et les Français le reconnaîtront
en Normandie tout à l'heure je vous
écoute maintenant et j'ai fait des
comparaisons et je me disais mais en
fait la droite française elle est où
est-ce que c'est Julien de Normandie qui
la représente ou c'est vous
et bien écoutez je joue
pas de droite et j'ai dit
de gauche d'extrême droite alors
certains disent que vous mais non plus
mais je vais vous le dire très
sincèrement vous avez pensé que c'est un
élément de langage mais c'est ma
véritable conviction et je suis très
fidèle à Marine je suis depuis longtemps
en ce moment mais je suis très fidèle à
Marine parce que sa ligne c'est ni
droite ni gauche national ou français
c'est comme ça qu'elle a déjà exprimé et
je crois vraiment que il y a des bonnes
idées à droite que ma gauche donc en
fait comme le président de la République
et de droite
et à gauche et nous étions prendre ce
qu'il y a de meilleur à droite et à
gauche voilà petite nuance qui peut y
avoir avec vous en République alors et
ça c'est je vous le dis je crois qu'il y
a des choses de bon sens il y a des
mesures de bon sens c'est le cas
notamment dans les mesures liées au
pouvoir d'achat que Marine Le Pen et
c'est mettre souhaiterait mettre en
place il y a aussi de très bonnes choses
autour de sujets comme c'est comme la
sécurité par exemple qui sont des sujets
régaliens et pourtant les observateurs
qui regardent la vie politique qui sont
avertis disent le front le rassemblement
national pardon
reste un parti protestataire on vote
parce que on est contre parce que on
veut pousser un coup de gueule si vous
me permettez l'expression un peu
d'ailleurs comme avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon
mais de l'autre côté de l'échiquier
politique qu'est-ce que vous dites de ça
alors là je crois que les commentateurs
qui le disaient à Saint-André je ne suis
pas convaincu qu'il le dise encore parce
que moi je n'entends plus il y a un
véritable adhésion et ce mode d'adhésion
il est il est démontré d'élection après
toutes les crises qu'on a pu vivre en
1998 avec la scission de Bruno Maigret
après le départ de maréchal Florent
Philippot on en a vu des moments
difficiles ces derniers mois aussi vous
savez le socle populaire du mouvement a
toujours été notre force et malgré donc
les tempêtes ben malgré que le bateau en
effet Tang et bien nous sommes toujours
là et je crois beaucoup dans ce socle
populaire qui et la force de notre
mouvement donc il y a un vote d'adhésion
mais pour gagner au second tour il faut
qu'on élargisse ce que là donc ça veut
dire qu'il y aura aussi un mode de rejet
parce que jamais un candidat sortant
président sortant de ressuscité autant
de rejets et de mépris
auprès des rentes quand même assez haut
oui mais viens en tête oui vous savez
Cyril Zemmour
d'Éric Zemmour on n'avait pas été
présent cette candidature
moi je n'ai jamais cru dans cette
candidature
est-ce que vous auriez été à 30 % par
exemple mais nous auriez été je pense
qu'ils ont été devant comme d'ailleurs
tous les sondages nous positionner en
tête avant l'été dernier si la créateurs
n'avait pas été là mais peu importe je
crois que la démocratie c'est aussi la
liberté pour tout le monde se présenter
il l'a fait indirectement mais écoutez
ça nous permet d'avoir un réservoir au
second tour Zemmour Le Pen Le Pen
Zemmour c'est la même chose non non
c'est pour ça que tout à l'heure vous
avez dit que
vous ne leur promettez rien aux émours
aux humoristes qu'une promesse a été
faite et je vous le dis une fois de plus
les lecteurs n'appartient à personne et
donc à tous les patrouilles gouvernement
il y aura pas des choses comme ça rien
rien alors la question elle se pose
évidemment
Marine Le Pen élue présidente de la
République avec qui gouverne telle on a
du mal à imaginer une Assemblée
nationale qui soit j'étais très qui soit
je dirais dirigé par le rassemblement
national précisément ça c'est un
argument que beaucoup nous adversaires
bien sûr utilisent
quand Emmanuel Macron a été élu sans
appareil sans parti politique on aurait
pu se poser samedi et soit là il était
l'homme du système probablement et
peut-être que la question était moins
suscité ça marche plus dans les semaines
en disant j'ai de quoi en constituer
trois gouvernements ne vous inquiétez
pas si demain elle gagne l'élection
présidentielle ça veut dire qu'elle a
50% et une loi des Français est-ce que
vous imaginez que dans 50% des électeurs
elle est pas capable de trouver un
gouvernement de 40 personnes
le gouvernement
deuxième étape en effet l'élection
législatives il lui faut une majorité
présidentielle mais jusqu'à preuve du
contraire il y a toujours une vague en
faveur du président élu
depuis que les objectifs ont lieu juste
après parce qu'il n'est pas grave vous
c'est avec eux au milieu du septonat et
on a assisté de cohabitation ce futur 86
et vu qu'en 95 mais je crois qu'elle
aura s'il est élu le président de la
République ça veut dire qu'un certain
nombre de Français ont compris que leur
destin est en jeu le 24 avril prochain
qui ne voudront plus d'un président qui
lui méprise comme il l'a fait qu'il en a
pas une retraite à 65 ans qui ne voudra
pas un président qui nous fait croire
seul démocratie qu'il avancera et qui ne
le fait pas donc je pense qu'il choisir
Marine Le Pen par par par par adhésion
donc vous n'avez pas dit la dernière
question
une réaction très claire ferme sur
Poutine tout à l'heure
ôtez-moi d'un doute vous n'avez plus
aucun lien financier avec des banques
russes
il y a une banque russe qui a qui était
Chico russe qui a des possibilités qui
étaient rachetés bon et donc qui nous
avait prêté de l'argent parce que pas
une seule banque française vous avez pas
été là
il reste 15 secondes et nous continuons
nous avons une audience mais c'est
remboursé vous remboursez toujours votre
empreinte à la banque bien sûr mais nous
avons aucun lien avec l'État c'est pas
une banque d'État et écoutez quand un
français prend un crédit pour acheter
une voiture en France il est pas lié
mais le Macron nous avons un crédit
parce que nous n'avons pas une seule
banque française cela pas de l'argent
viens malheureusement si vous avez
demain le contact dans votre réseau
éventuellement à financier de nos
campagnes on sera ravi de le faire
je n'ai pas le temps de vous demander
comme à Julien de Normandie si vous
allez gagner il m'a dit mais parce que
vous nous avez dit oui tout à l'heure
donc c'est fait merci merci beaucoup
d'avoir été invité de
d'audition publique vous vous êtes
arrivés essoufflé vous repartez soufflez
vous avez beaucoup parlé
mais ça fait plaisir bonne soirée à tous
sur la chaîne parlementaire
[Musique]